hey Michael I'm looking through my
appointment book and I don't see your
name you know a lot more about walking
not you know that walk-ins are more
expensive but I'm always happy to
accommodate sure you'll accommodate me
as long as I got right I'm in a bad way
thought I might come by soon
you
[Music]
if I was the car of people
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I own act like a tough
guy
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you Lester you gotta let me enter
what I was wondering when you'd show up
I was dead
praise be guess you weren't very dead
you need my help
how do you know cuz you came here what
else would you I haven't been a good
friend for you Lester I know that and
you're gonna make it up to me by doing
whatever I ask a rather I mean I need
something done you need to know
something so why not help each other I
got to make some dough see you back in
the game I guess look Lester about what
happened before I know you never
mentioned my name no I'm not on any
lists anywhere I know you never betrayed
me as for you you got to figure that I
never told anyone that instead of gently
decomposing in North Yankton you're
angrily decomposing in little Santos
with a shrink and a wife who don't love
you no more since you put it like that
shut up a minute I'm getting an I find
alert that little college boys sack of
[ __ ] phony [ __ ] who J Norris yes that
[ __ ] is a lying bastard I've read his
[ __ ] emails he's a [ __ ] cheat I
heard him say that he saved America what
by outsourcing all the jobs by selling
us little bits of plastic restricted
access [ __ ]
well now it's payback time you lying
turd the hell are you talking about you
are about to get that white-collar gig
that you always dreamed of Mikey here
take this fashionably retro weird for a
45 year old man but I cannot let go of
the 1980s bag and dress yourself up like
a billionaire math genius with low-level
Asperger's
you better be ready for the minor glitch
of your repulsive pseudo messianic life
okay Lester get out of here call me when
you're ready
we are about to put the darwinism back
on social Darwinism and brother it is
gonna be fine you [ __ ] kidding me I'm
a bank robber not a web design so we'll
go robbing soon I'll find something just
like the old days
I'd offer you something but you were
just leaving
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] it dick
ah excuse me I got this interview at
this tech company thinking I need
something I don't know
geeky youth lost your job in the world's
moved on huh that's too bad I didn't
lose my job of course got too old got
outsourced same thing happened to my dad
now you got to fit in with a different
generation hmm
what about a vest and some cargo shorts
you
you know no definitely not
you
hey it's Lester I don't listen to my
messages but I probably listen to yours
do with that as you will
dignity aside I think that might just
work
good luck at the interview goodbye
[Music]
Michael I'm all dressed up now you want
to run me through this thing the
prototype is somewhere in the life
Invader office find it and fit it with
the device in your bag they're just
gonna let me in
why wouldn't they if you look the part
hang around til someone opens the door
act entitled fine
you're an idiot
hey-ya oh great there are PM's pushing
for more functionality
you
what I mean I'm turning consultant when
we release consulting consulter x' you
know a consultancy consultancy
consultancy and kind of big on the
conference tour already
oh hi chill out on the beanbag Markus
will be right out oh I'm gonna take a
normal chair I have a terrible back here
you go if you guys let me use the OS I
requested this wouldn't be a problem oh
you've been added on this PC uh got any
antivirus software I think so
behind this junk on the left clicked and
NSFW linked burrow bit me on the ass
yeah not safe for work uh-huh you know
my son's computer runs into the same
kind of problems
I'll close the pop-ups see what I can do
your son codes stop the merge bro you
let your best stuff in your tweens after
that it's just a hack job hmm guess I
gotta close the rest of them down there
you go how about I run the antivirus
software and now we scan scanning
my I get all these migraines seriously
and that should do it
why don't you try and keep things
strictly safe for work from now on
hey have you seen the prototype in the
demo room when Norris announces it at
the keynote minds are gonna blow nice
dude when it blue screens again you're
my god
bye
sit sit sit sit sit sit sit put back dig
back oh come on you're gonna have to
learn the foot bag if you want to get a
job here okay follow me okay all right
follow me okay
some hey hold my head oh there was a
hard-on I'll buzz you out
[Music]
hey Lester the things in the prototype
I'm going along to watch the keynotes
payback time my friend Lester did you
hear me
are you playing that game yeah yeah
sorry phone is rigged now what's your
problem
you don't like shooters Oh same sights
you know me I'm a movie guy classic
binary classic vine what ended 30 years
ago now it's just superheroes romantic
comedies and remakes none of which
interest me hey I believe this country
could still make interesting movies
there's no better way to define American
life and a two-hour plot in which the
hero looks good and defeats evil now
whatever you say enjoy yesterday anyway
just call the device after he's unveiled
it and then we'll talk
Santa's free way are the Chinese coming
after our illegal drugs now epsilon ISM
still growing and still popular within
prowl the Transit Authority announces
another project residents will ignore a
60s arthouse classic returns to cinemas
shop and tear on the del carril freeway
earlier as two groups of
engage in a high-speed gun back
I'm sorry
and tore through my artery now if you
don't mind
the press conference today global poll
share in town
[Applause]
legally in recent months
to infiltrate the North American drug
market
my recent controversies including a
court case
and accusations
of being a cult
choosing to become Epsilon
oh my god you guys are so lean no I'm
watching Famer Shane [ __ ] tits mines
on fire ladies and gentlemen please
welcome mr. J Norris to the stage
Hey
this company has come a long way since
we started it in my parents pool house
in East Carroll today you're about to
witness a new face full on weapons-grade
red alert world domination
we're put a billion people's private
data in the public domain and we have
melt every penny we could in the process
we have one of the youngest workforces
in the world an average age of only
fourteen point four years that's not
just impressive it's revolutionary
today right here we are now to make the
next step
prepare to witness the future the life
invader mobile device
yes we've invented something no one else
has ever thought of hold on a second
here I think someone's trying to talk
with me oh Jesus whoa
you